patience perhaps the most noble of all  the virtues there will be times in your  life when temptation confronts you with  its little piggy face and you must  decide what breed of character are you  do you have any restraint at all  or are you merely driven by base  animalistic instinct  can you hold yourself back even if it  means competing on merits like  intelligence speed and the ability to  smell bacon  yes patience waiting until the perfect  moment wait whoa whoa whoa where did the  little dog come from it's not fair I  hate to say it but that was a bummer I'm  having a bummer time now not cool but he  is kind of cute he looks like a little  evil Benji  oh well humility and forgiveness perhaps  the most noble of all the virtues but  just so you know little man next time  we'll see who jumps first  [Music]